I thought you'd be excited to have an acting job.
If it's an acting job, we should get paid.
Yeah, you're gonna get paid in experience.
I wanna actually get paid.
All right, what do you want?
Six hundred dollars for the day, plus overtime if we go over eight hours.
I'll do my own hair and makeup.
And I want you to pay for the six-week intensive acting camp that my mom can't afford.
Fifty dollars for the day and a two-week acting class at the YMCA nearest you.
Five hundred dollars and a four-week acting class.
Three hundred dollars and a three-week class.
Done.
I would have done it for 500.
I would have done it for the experience.
Michael, you're up. Opener?
I want you to take me to Hawaii so I can swim with the dolphins.
You're not gonna let that one go, are you?
We're not going to Hawaii, pal. Anything else?
Find someone else then.
The Mafia staredown.
Very good, Michael.
We're here to negotiate.
Do you have anything else you might like?
I want a flying pony.
I want a flying pony too, Michael, but they don't exist.
Then I want a regular pony.
And I want to name him Nelson.
How about a Playstation 3 and we name him Nelson?
Keep talking.
We'll include four video games.
Five games.
And I want the meeting with Blondie to be at J.D. McFunnigan's.
How about Charlie Choo-Choo's because it's right down the street from me?
Mention that slop hole again and I walk.
All right, take it easy, son. Take it easy.
And I want unlimited tokens.
If I can spend 'em, I wanna have 'em.
I don't wanna be like playing Skee-Ball and all of a sudden run out of tokens.
All right, I can make that happen.
So, do we have a deal?
Deal.